the paper is
ran from University of Oxford and he
will talk about range avoidance and
yourself
so I am going to talk about Grand
evidence and the hard pressure
adjustables unfortunately I don't have
time for remote point today if you want
to talk about remote funds you can come
to me offline and this is a joint work
with my lovely causes
uh uh they are uh area from San Antonio
University
also from University they are very
talented and hardworking young
researchers so uh also I didn't find a
photo of here and but please believe me
he's very handsome
so
another very very very important point I
want to emphasize is
um there are senior undergraduate
students and they are applying for PhD
so if you see their name on your
application Pro please accept the
the application
yeah you can forget about what I'll
mentioned later but please remember this
slide
and uh now uh let me start by mentioning
something uh deceptively simple maybe I
can say this that is through my lower
Bound for crfs so you probably know that
CF is this class of depth 2 circles well
at the top you have an end gate oh by
the way if you have any question please
feel free to interrupt me
um so on the top you have an end gate of
unbounded plan e and on the bottom you
have all Gates
so this looks like an easy question
right if you have some function called
parity then you know it is hard for
sales actually it's exponentially hard
and you even understand the optimal
property
um because like each zero in the
adjustable parity requires one or get at
the at the bottom so the optimal side is
2 to n minus one so anyway that's not
important I'm just illustrating that you
have a very good understanding of this
circle class seemingly
but what about when you are only given a
partial info set
so here is the question I have a table
where on the left hand side I have some
inputs and on the right hand side I have
question marks I want to replace each
question mark by a bit zero or one such
that uh what I get is a partial function
that is hard for CNF circuits
if this doesn't make sense then I have
my next slide has a slightly more formal
definition of this
so
uh so this is a computational problem
where you get as input L strings of
length n and you can think of L as
something between poly and the tutor and
for concrete is think of it as
sub-explanation and
uh
your output will be fits y1 up to yl
which are Beats is to fill in the
question marks
and the requirement is that the partial
function from x i to y i you get will be
hard for thin and formulas
uh which means for any field and formula
of poly and sides uh there exists some I
said that c fails to compute uh X fails
to map x i to y i
so it's this definition clear
it needs to be distinct I guess uh yes
yes
uh and maybe some version of termination
you can come up with zero outside but
now we are in a hard mode
um so this question uh when you maybe
when you first look at this question uh
let me think parity it's hard for them
so maybe party or Manhattan on this
partial function so we can just plug in
the results of parity here but then you
realize oh sorry so for a certain short
lists there's I would say you're saying
Elvis is Big so yeah
this will always have
a solution yes I'll talk about that
later
thanks
and uh
so you're very imperative here but you
you uh after a while you realize there's
a problem if I give you the set of
inputs where parity becomes zero then
you will give me the order function
which has a trigger they have circuit so
this problem is not as pure as you think
and uh actually it's open
uh we don't know if this problem has a
non-trivial polynomial time solution of
course I mean this polynomial time
any questions
or is it a function oh it's a search
Problem
or a function
you don't need to Output a lot of bits
right
answers no
um
like that there's always going to be
somewhere yes
difference
what is the problem I'm giving the list
and given the excise and the Y eyes no
you're given the excise yeah and I'm not
given the white eyes
or so as to make it a hard problem so
the problem and it's hard part
of this problem is
actually you need to find other piece
why I said that the partial function
becomes hard for us so by heart you can
just make it like square root of L you
need squared about
uh you mean
yeah you can fix some uh Circle sizes
is there a relation to other
um promise kind problems for for ac0 or
AC or CNF like for instance Computing
parties we know that CNF or ac0 cannot
compute party
but now it's open whether you can
compute by AC 0 and possibly even by CNF
and for some a set of parties that does
not trivially span the parity of all
inputs it's open whether you can compute
whether there exists a set of parties
um
that do not spend the party of all
inputs and yet it's hard for CNF to
compute party from parties so this is
just to interrupt this discussion but we
should not
talk
ourselves
okay
I think your special we can take it
offline
and oh sorry but I just have a quick
clarification about the problem so
um
it's not should it be clear to us that
there always exists such a why what
through yl yes and uh actually yeah and
I try to learn proof I mean it's a
larger much larger than the polysads
here
like now it's two subscribers and but
the third parameter is only fully and if
this is the case then you can prove that
always exists is also
because there are two CDL possible
functions right oh U.S boiling my slides
it's an interesting problem and it's
also uh frustrating that we know a lot
about staff but we still cannot solve
this problem
alcohol
so uh if you don't know what HCC zero
circuit is then it's fine because you
don't need it in this work in this talk
but it's uh some second class that's
much stronger than CNF and it's in some
sense a frontier class in current
circular bounds
so now let me address the question that
many of you are concerned with why is
there a solution at all
uh okay
let's say there are L inputs and we will
require harness against sites as
circuits
if L is less than S let's say much less
than S then there's no solution and you
can always like hard code of the answers
by a a CF of cells slightly larger than
l but L is greater than as the the
existed solution and it can be proved by
the probability method because the proof
is important I'll go through it so there
are only like uh roughly to the as many
circuits
uh so this article maybe it's not
clearly so you can see from there uh and
uh but there are uh like two or possible
partial functions because each question
mark has two possible choices
so each circuit can only give you one
partial function so there are always
some partial functions that are not
mapped
so uh if L is much larger than S then
there has to be some partial function
not computed by any circuit and your
task is just to pick out such a partial
function
uh if I ask you again why is there a
solution you might answer the answer
it's the empty period principle what is
antibodial principle if you are if you
throw Ambitions into mhost
uh
uh well and it's less than m
you will throw Ambitions into amp holes
in some arbitrary way
and it's less than M then there has to
be an empty pigeon hole actually there
has to be at least n minus and empty
pigeon holes
in this talk let's consider the weak
version where let's say n is much less
than M let's say n is less than mo2
so you can see that what guarantees a
solution in the hot pressure level it's
exactly this empty personal principle
uh and now let me introduce
um the the main subject in in the stock
that is the range of audience problem
in this problem you are given as input a
circuit from NBS to our bits where L is
greater than n
and you want to find some string y
That's not in the range of C so for any
x c x is not equal to Y and we are
called this Y and now output of C
uh you can so this problem corresponds
to the weekend typical principle you can
think of the second c as it Maps the it
Maps a pigeon into a hole so there are
two different and there are two to our
holes given the index of a picture C
tells you how to map it to a whole and
you just want to find an empty hole so
I'll I'll give you some examples on why
this is the problem that corresponds to
like a weak empty original principle but
now I also want to remark that this is
the white box version of the missing
stream problem that Ryan just discussed
this morning
oh
and this one has a true randomized
algorithm because you can see like most
strings are known outputs of C so you
can just output a random string and uh
wish that it works but we are really
interesting with music algorithms for
this problem
uh
so let me illustrate that Ranger
audience corresponds to weak and
divisional principle by giving a
reduction from hard pressure adjustable
to range avoidance if you still remember
what how partial adjustable is uh the
input it's a list of input strings and
the right hand side of this table is not
filled yet
now we reduce it to the following
instance of range avoidance note that
each instance is a stretching circuit
so the input of this instance is the
description of a dnf frequency which
only takes like three as long as speeds
and the output is the right hand side
that this c maps too
so it's a combination of c x y up to c x
l
um if 3 as log s is less than L then
there has to be a solution and
any questions
and if you find another output of this
circuit then you plug it back here and
you get a hard partial suitable
is everything clear
yeah so this is exactly what was
happening in our uh so-called
probabilistic method proof and what this
circuit does is it Maps the circuit to
the accessible
so you can see that I mentioned the two
things before the first thing is the
existence of a solution is granted by
the weak and divisional principle and
the second thing is that the search
problem is reducible to range avoidance
and they are the same thing
um
in general there is a phenomenon of
explicit constructions
and there are some property P that
people are interested in and you can use
the weak and diffusional principle to
show that a random object satisfies p
with hyperability and on the other hand
it's uh it's very hard to shoot it
musically construct any string any
object that satisfies P
some Infamous examples are hardships
where some people call circular bonds uh
uh religious messages and the
ramsagraphs if you don't know about the
little two it's okay because uh I'll
just uh illustrate them as examples
um yeah we're a nice paper bag uh
he showed that Ranger audience is this
problem that captures explicit
constructions in the sense that
uh for all this uh natural explicit
construction problems uh you can reduce
it to range of audience
uh so if you can sell Ranger audience
then you can so I'll just explicit
construction problems
and the more the reduction itself it's
essentially the proof that the
probabilistic method
so for example uh to find a hydro table
you just need to uh do the ranger
audience for the so-called trustable
generator
this generator uh takes us input a small
circuit and then expands the circuit
into two table and output the adjustable
so if you have enough of this generator
then you have a hard function
and uh the other examples I don't have
time to Define here
[Music]
now let me like uh look into what has
happened in circular bounds and see if
they are give insights on General
explicit constructions and range of
audience
in like uh a decade ago oh yeah it's
again
yeah around a decade ago and ran through
this breaks through the result that any
XP is not in ACC 0. here again HTT is
this a frontier circular class and we
don't know how to prove accent by other
ways
and what's nice about this proof is that
it has two steps the first step uh you
have a round shoulders
a so-called non-trailer algorithm for
so-called State PP for ac0 uh I'll try
to explain what it means but later uh
but the second step is he also shows
such an algorithm implies circular
bounds
so what is CPP CPP is this circuit
acceptance probability problem
uh up your input to say PPP is some
circular c a single output circuit C and
you want to estimate the probability
that c accepts a random input
with additive error let's say constant
it's clear that there are two algorithms
for CPP the first two algorithm is you
just sample a bunch of random inputs and
test C against this random inputs
so this is a poly and randomized
algorithm
and the second algorithm is you just do
Brute Force you invest through all
inputs is tutor and probably a dignity
time now in Trivial algorithm means you
need to beat the beats the true audit
Mythic algorithm so you want to run in
time slightly less than two to one time
uh and it's impressive that even this
very marginal improvement over the
trivial purpose algorithm gives you some
circular amount
uh and this connection is very general
uh right actually showed that for any
typical typical circular Class C uh if
you have an unsure algorithm for say PPP
problem of C here your input is a c
circuit
if you have a natural algorithm for
safety of seats and exp is not contained
in C
uh in this talk let's use this slightly
weaker bound that e2mp is not in three
uh e2mp not insect corresponds to
um polynomial time uh algorithm for
range of evidence with MP Oracle
so let's recall this two simple
generator it takes this uh description
of an Exit 0 circuit C and mapped it to
a interestable
so what rhyme proved
uh it's essentially that the range
avoidance problem for the specific
trustable generator has an unconditional
fp2mp algorithm
to see why it holds like uh your first
notice that the truth about generator
the output lens is tutor and and
therefore polynomial attempt algorithm
for Ranger rodents becomes exponential
time algorithm for constructing a hard
shoe stable
[Music]
um
so just naturally leads to the following
questions uh is there anything special
about super generous and can we do like
General range avoidance
uh this was the motivating question
where I was uh doing when I started
doing this project
we wanted to generalize the algorithmic
method to General range avoidance
problem sorry when you say in the
previous slide when you say for this
specific range avoidance this actually
holds so for any ecc0 circuit I can do
the range avoidance right
no no I'm just the same for this
specific generator uh the generator
takes us input and this is the circuit
and outputs the traceable of the uh
circuit so you're seeing one generator
but where you're saying if I give a
generic SEC 0 circuit you cannot solve
range of audience uh yeah that's uh our
new result
okay okay all right thanks so is this
function
tea cereal because you need to have like
a universal
evaluation
uh for HCC zero I believe it's still
interested
well some uh not very typical class like
this is maybe you cannot do that
but like depth five basically
yes yes
so if this input has that feed them and
in this circle has left larger than the
maybe 30 or something I don't know
with another undergraduate student uh we
got some algorithm methods for rent
evidence we showed that something called
non-trivial Heming with estimation data
structures implies algorithm for lunch
Awards
let me explain what this this structure
is
the uh the death structure receives a
circuit for purposes the circuit has
more outputs than inputs
it has a primrocessing phase and a
career phase during the preposition
phase uh yeah you receive the circuit
you computer that structure you have MP
or alcohol
and in the current phase you are given
an input of the circuit you want to
estimate the Heming weights of CX that
is estimate how many output bits are one
given this input but you want to do it
in non-trivial accurate time which means
this Mythic time less than l or is the
opulence
of course you have Oracle access to the
data structure otherwise I think it's
impossible for generosity
uh you can see that on CPP is indeed
Hemingway estimation for the true Sable
generator uh to see why uh what is the
Hemi weight is measure problem for TT
it's doing accurate you are given an
input X which is a zip which is a
circuit you want to estimate the Heming
weight of the true stable of the circuit
which is estimates the probability that
the second objects one only random input
so hopefully this is clear and uh this
is this result is a generalization of
Brands algorithm method
uh any questions
which is the generalization can we
invoke a new data structure
I'm trying to understand what is the
generalization here uh data structure
and then you characterize the properties
of this data structures being saved by
um cap
no I just put me uh right slow down is a
special test of uh this new result
because if you plug the C being the r27
generator then you just need to solve
the ATP in order to find another key
I knew another side to compare this
these two results the algorithmic method
says that non-trailer algorithms running
in this much time for CPP implies
circular bounds and our results is uh
non-trail debt structures running in
this much current time with some ptmp
purposes for Hemingway estimation of C
implies uh efficient MP algorithm for
range avoidance
[Music]
this is one difference and another
difference is to we can deal with our
visual obituary circuits like a visual
improved of Ranger water
[Music]
and uh sorry and your conclusion in the
last slide doesn't imply a second
overbound uh could you say again
your conclusion at the bottom right most
uh
awareness does this imply yeah
uh if you can Implement through server
generator in this class C like suitable
channels for another secret class for in
this implies circle around
uh Does this answer your question
okay okay so and can you do it for uh
classes like uh
the ones for the algorithmic method like
kcc0 and the other ones uh we can do HCC
zero but uh uh I don't know if we can do
s is there of threshold because that is
that doesn't seem to be Universal
so you're saying in terms of actual
applications what you're getting is
actually weaker in terms of lower bounds
for circuits you get other things but
for secretary bouncy it's not quite this
generalized algorithmic method is is
what you're saying
uh could you repeat the question in
terms of circuit Rover bounds you're
saying that the current applications of
your techniques are weaker than what we
know with the algorithmic methods
um
maybe you still need a universality okay
so okay thanks for the question
for the algorithmic method you also need
universality the other class or no I
don't think so
things
like I apologize
[Music]
so uh one drawback of the first paper is
W is that uh tell me where the
estimation appears to be hard and we
didn't get very good unconditional
results
um in the new paper we showed that
natural algorithms for satisfying pairs
which is another problem also imply a
video empty algorithm for range
avoidance so what is 37 pairs
uh it's not a description problem it's
just a static static problem
uh the input consists of n circuits and
M inputs
for now think of the capital and capital
M being much larger than Circle size and
input size
um and what you want to do is to
estimate the number of IJ such that CI
of XJ is one
you can see that this is in some sense
an offline version of payment
information
on this uh these three circuits uh gives
you a multi-autumn circuit
I mean this in circles you can think of
it as one multiple circuit and the
inputs in Hemingway is mentioned they
are given in an online fashion but here
you just get a batch of inputs and
instead of
um instead of outputting the Hemi weight
for each set of x i you just need the
average Heming weight
uh so actually
um
okay so uh this is so this is such a
simple problem any questions
this capital N is like l in the last
time
I guess so
and uh you can think of it as you have a
table over rows or circles and the
colors are inputs the answer is one if
the circuit accepts the input and is
zero otherwise
you want to estimate the fraction of
interest that is 1. but you want to do
it in non-zerial term which means you
don't have time to construct the whole
table
well your influence is roughly and plus
them but the table and table size is NM
so you want to beat this sugar and time
um
also you can use some kind of meeting in
the middle to show CPP reduces to 2 to
our two circles and two times two input
37 pairs
foreign
[Music]
for sure
the way you do the reduction is to like
say pick the person over two variables
yeah and set them in all ways and
restrict the circuit the single circuit
in all two to the N over two ways to
create your family but that's a very
uniform family whereas the general
satisfying fairs problem involves
circuits that might be totally unrelated
yes that's true
so is that the main difference why
whether isn't like an equivalence
uh
on the other hand the input lens of cftp
is just circular size but influence for
such fan pairs it's like capital N plus
capital M it's like square root of the
Brute Force time
so I don't think these two problems are
equivalent
and uh
we also observed that implicit in
previous work was an unsure algorithm
for HTC 0 satisfying pairs so we'll just
plug in this algorithm to our framework
we get an FP to MP algorithm for HCC
General range avoidance
and
so there's uh I I omitted the parameter
setting like uh what's the what's the
circle size and what's the stretch uh
just uh just think of the if some like
natural parameter set in foreign works
and this result also recovers the best
it is a circular bonds because our DOT
is a generalization of other person
about and uses uh like uh I mean in
terms of use like that lower belt to get
here yeah yeah we at least use the your
techniques and maybe it has some new new
things
okay
and come back to the uh just simple
problem and we can uh we can use this
render audience without to show this and
a picture empty algorithms that only
input a uh the domain of a project table
and the fifth this partial suitable so
that it's hard against the accuses or
circuits
again I didn't mention for which
parameter region
foreign
avoidance
second proof it's you you don't need
universality in this case and you can
run this algorithmic method again
what you get is non-trivial algorithm
for C successful Health imply efficient
algorithm for C hard part of sustainable
and this doesn't need universality
okay I'm not going a little bit fast
oh thanks so let me uh let me promote an
open question that I really want to see
it solved
the problem is to solve the answer the
ranger avoidance in a video Until with
maybe a small polynomial stretch
foreign
uh anyway but uh I was thinking that
until the one 1.01 might be approachable
but now I don't know
zero three you have only two layers or
it's just constant number
if if it's entry zero then then each
other bit only depends on constant
number of input bits and it doesn't
matter how many layers there are and
there's three here just indicates the
locality
[Music]
oh sorry I actually don't know how this
everything looks
um
so it's toughest to solve the following
again enough and looking hypergraph
problem
your input is a seven uniform hypograph
consisting of little and what is the
capital and Hyper agents you are also
given some cuts so a half about it's
just a set of vertices and a set of
hyper edges seven uniform means each
type of edge contains exactly seven
vertices
like the uh I think I dropped four hyper
edges
a card is some way to partition the
vertices into two parts
and the
we say a cut goes through an edge if the
edge intersects both parts of the card
so this card goes through the orange
Edge
also go through the blue edge but it
doesn't go through the purple Edge and
the green Edge
I hope I hope this makes sense
and you want to estimate the number of
ijs that the JS card goes through the s
h paper Edge
so
and you
oh I didn't mention that sure okay
so yeah
I see thanks so uh if you can solve this
innocent looking hypergraph problem in
Nigeria the specific time then you get a
good algorithm for instance of the range
avoidance
and uh you you can probably see this is
just a variant of nc-0 satisfying pairs
and one point I didn't mention it's uh
like our HTC Zero avoidance algorithm
only works for quantity polynomial
stretch so the number of if the if there
are like an inputs then there are there
should be like two two uh poly log and
outputs in order for our algorithm to
work
doesn't doesn't help to solve the NCAA
audience here because so this problem
[Music]
the question is can you do it in wood
here
what is the uh the question can you do
it in uh
but uh I have two problems here first is
the nc03 award second it's a happy
birthday the second one oh
so you are just given just uh have a
graph and cut and you want to estimate
the number of compare number of Health
okay yes
products
and and over a long time and ends
uh sure I was announcing uh
and you want to share times and in the
first points oh it's uh you need to save
some lot better here so maybe I should
add a parenthesis on this vlogs
so the end to the 100 is the same as the
1.1 the point
um maybe not I haven't calculated the
parameters
um maybe it just means your application
and the algorithm takes into 100 times
oh so into 1.01 should be this way I
guess
it's professors uh I want to prove it's
equivalent but I'm stuck
even though
hopefully hopefully
um so if everything is clear then we
jump to my final flight there's a
summary of this part
I introduced this Ranger audience
program which is uh which uh
in some sense characterizes
principle and if you solve this problem
you will have dramatic consequence in
explicit Construction
and uh to solve this problem in fp2mp is
the best is to
um to solve something called the sub
samples that a non-trivial algorithm
and finally just have a uh some
application to the hard pressure
adjustable problem
and we can solve this problem with an MP
Oracle but without NPR code it seems to
be completely open
and that's all for today thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
connections between rage range of
avoidance for different classes
non-trivial connections like nc03 and
it's zero 10 do you know if any oh nice
custom we have in this monstrous region
we have a reduction from let's say why I
want to and see there are Awards so
smart switch means you map from nvs to n
plus one bits
uh which means for this open question if
you can solve it for n plus one first
then for each one periodical
exponentials formula which would be very
strong but as far as I know for larger
stress there is no dramatic consequence
so it's the same issues as with stress
for low volts like yes
the same issues here as with low
complexity prgs like NC or prgs but you
know having stretch and do one
perception versus an expression small
small stretches in Corvette C1 yeah even
the first technique side effects yeah
there's more questions
you have better set alarms does this
just to improve like the stretch for
which you can solve avoidance or does it
actually help you out real quickly uh I
think it just uh improves the stretch
and so in our family we didn't get very
tight about but yes or imagine that you
can you can order with like like lower
stretches yeah
uh
[Music]
three award algorithm for stretch n to
the one plus n to the 1.01 stretch
yeah yeah this slide
like if you if you solve nc03 award for
this stretch then does it imply any
explicit constructions
or n to the 1.01
I don't know it's just out of curiosity
actually many explicit constructions
were used to range of audience but only
in small stretch regime
that's a very nice research question
like can solve it in small strategy okay
so energy is really if it's R2 it's a
question
uh if it's already two the GLW paper
solved it you have a stretch and plus
one anything for normal time without NPR
without NPR so that also implies
algorithm for the 65 degree I don't
think so actually such a fan pair also
gives you remote Point algorithm and
I'll be answerable two remote point is
open
nice okay
yeah would you say just one sentence
with your scriptures
yeah so
you want to find some strength who's
Heming with it's far from any string in
the range of circuit so that's the
remote point for that you can still
approve by probabilistic government
argument that this string exists
and a good enough that stem hair
algorithm gives you efficiency algorithm
for remote point
so thank you again